high level Carmichael welcome to another
edition of ask Evan today I'm going to
answer question from one of our readers
Max who runs a company called orange
digital marketing and he wrote in with a
question about his company and he wanted
to know how do I manage a fast-growing
company that is taking on a lot of new
employees so thanks to the question max
I'm going to give you three suggestions
that I hope will help hire the right
person one at a time the number one
mistake that most high growth companies
will make its hiring the wrong people
too quickly it makes sense you're
busting at the seams and need to bring
people on board to get all the work done
especially businesses with under ten
employees every new hire is critical
you're hiring should have both the
skills you aren't and the cultural and
values fit that will let them thrive in
your company if they don't meet your
requirements keep searching until you
get the right candidate it's far better
to hire right and have someone thrive in
a position than to be constantly
replacing the position because you
didn't hire properly at the beginning
it's less headache will save you time
and money in the long run and will
provide you with a much better working
culture if you take your time and do it
properly here's an example from Jeff
Bezos from amazon com one of the biggest
factors behind the amazing success of
amazon is the people the company has
behind it from day one Jeff Bezos has
made it his priority to hire very
carefully it might not have been the
company's best use of resources but
Bezos was taking a long-term perspective
he wanted this company to have a long
shelf life I knew that with his stop
you'd be create an enduring culture
according to Bezos I'd rather interview
50 people and not hire anyone that hired
the wrong person ensure new hires get
proper training another big problem with
rapidly growing companies is that they
don't train new employees enough even if
you take your time and hiring the right
person you have to make sure you set
them up for success once they come on
board you want to have high expectations
but not impossible ones make sure you
set in your schedule time to work with
them to explain how you do things
and always be available for questions if
they have them no matter how busy you
are the last thing you want is for your
team to be afraid to approach you with
questions and ideas inadequate training
leads to bad morale a loss of
productivity and ultimately an inferior
product or service being produced if
hiring and training both fall on your
shoulders you might have to hold off on
hiring someone new until the first
person hired is fully trained and ready
to go here's an example from Ray Kroc
from mcdonalds a strong component of
teamwork crock understood that his grown
company could only continue its meteoric
rise up if it had to support an a
dedication of its workers behind it in
the early stages of the business crock
personally took charge of the entire
hiring process once he'd made the
decision to bring someone on board the
McDonald's team crock would give each
and every one of them a badge which a
title of management trainee it didn't
matter what their actual job was crock
wanted every employee to feel valuable
and like an important part of the team
according to crock none of us is as good
as all of us McDonald's is a people
business and that smile on that counter
girls face when she takes you order is a
vital part of our image turn away
customers I hate turning away business
but I can't accept taking on customers
and then not delivering an outstanding
result for them if you're growing beyond
what your team can produce and you're
taking the right approach to hire and
train properly it may mean you can't
take on every new client that comes to
and that's okay there are two positives
here first you'll be able to pick your
clients and only work with the ones that
are more in that of an ideal fit for
your business second if you position it
properly with your potential client it
will just make them want to work with
you even more we all want what we can't
have and they'll be impressed with your
dedication to quality and customer
service chances are when you are ready
for the business they'll still be ready
for you another option here it could be
the subcontract to another company until
you're able to wrap up enough internally
to handle the business if you go this
route make sure that your subcontractors
have the same dedication of outstanding
service and quality that you do the last
thing you want to do is deliver a
substandard experience to your client
here's an example from Debbie fields
from mrs. Fields Cookies fields once
walked into one of her stores to see a
long line of customers waiting to
purchase a huge batch of cookies that
she immediately knew have been over
baked feels was upset she didn't want
those cookies to be sold or for those
customers to associate her name with
over baked cookies fields approached the
manager to figure out what was going on
what do you think of these cookies
fields asked him he was fired by saying
Oh Debbie they're good enough Fields was
upset and immediately threw out all the
cookies good enough she said good enough
never is Fields now had a long line of
hungry customers waiting to buy cookies
that had just been tossed into the
garbage she went over to them and
explained one by one what had happened
we've over baked these cookies she said
and I want them to be perfect and
whatever you're standing in line for I
will absolutely give them to you free
plus all match for free if you will come
back thank you for watching another
edition of ask Evan if you like the
video you want to see more please give
it a thumbs up below what makes you want
to do more of these videos for you guys
I'd also love to hear what you have to
think if you want to leave a comment
under the video I always read those and
I really appreciate them when they come
in and if you have a question about your
own business and you want me to do a
video answer you can also leave it in
the comments below and we'll consider
you for the next video so thank you and
we'll see you on the next episode
you